ううっうぅうううおおおおおお
今から日本語の講座を行います
って言いたいんですけど
そのとおりです今週も動画出せません
けれど
なんと今回はちゃんとした言い訳がありますそれは何なにかって言ってへ僕あの
macbook pro を使ってるんですけどまぁ今ここにあるんですが
キーボードが悪くなっていて今 j のキーが押せないんです
で推せないんでまあ僕いつも日本について動画を
か今書いてるんで j が押せないっていうのがちょっと記名的な状況なのでしょうが
なく修理に出すことになりました
以前にも別の
理由で出すことあるんでたぶん1週間くらいに戻ってくると思うんですが
まあ
パソコンが難易間はちょっととぅ
もちろん動画投稿できないんでちょっとっているしてください許してください
ででパソコンでも戻ってきたときは
いつもいつもとちょっと違う感じの動画を出そうと思っているんでそれ以上のことを
ちょっと言えないんですがまあ僕のチャンネルが好きな人たちだったら多分喜んで
くれるんじゃないかなと思いますのでぜひ楽しみにしていただけたらと思っています
問わないのかなぁ
いつもこうやって何だろう客音無しの動画を作る時を相当緊張し
するしのんだろうことなら
全然でないんですけどまぁこれでいいでしょう
エイズをどう間でした今後ともよろしくお願いしますすいませんいつもこんな8つまん
ない感じですはい以上
同源でした
じゃあねえ
やいいのかなぁ